hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're
gonna talk about iodine iodine facts there's
very interesting mineral it's a trace mineral
trace minerals are minerals that are needed in
smaller amounts okay so 30% of the body iodine is
stored in the thyroid gland okay the thyroid gland
concentrates iodine and it uses iodine to make its
hormones so when you see t4 and t3 3 & 4 represent
the number of iodine molecules in that hormone
t4 is an inactive form of thyroid and then t3
is the active form of thyroid and it's converted
through the liver and the kidney okay so 70% a
greater amount of iodine is in the salivary glands
it's in the breasts then the ovaries the stomach
lining the eyes the cerebral spinal fluid it's
in the substantia nigra that's in your a part
of your brain so it's not just necessarily in the
thyroid so iodine is important in many different
things in preventing fibrocystic breasts I mean
this is like the easiest thing to get rid of it
you give someone iodine I mean that stuff just
goes right away assists on the ovaries so the
female reproductive organs need iodine iodine
tends to lower estrogen in the body it actually
converts estradiol to estriol the good estrogen
so that's pretty cool so if there's an estrogen
dominant situation you would want to take sea kelp
or iodine so with the stomach lining the eyes even
in the eyes if you're deficient iodine you can
actually get little tumors in the eye cerebral
spinal fluid Parkinson's in the substantia nigra if you're deficient in iodine parkinson's so so
there's a lot of different other health problems
that are related to iodine but the body doesn't
necessarily store iodine it basically 90% of it
goes through your kidneys and you get rid of it
so you have to constantly get it in the diet
which is not easy because unless you're doing
seek help or or seafood or you're buying food
that is from a shoreline by the ocean you're
not going to get a lot of iodine because of the
soils are so depleted so it also is made to make
hormones we talked about that convert estrogen
rids heavy metals so when people take iodine or sea kelp
and they get a reaction instantly they think
that it's an allergy but not necessarily all the
time the reaction could be the detoxification of
heavy metals or chemicals like bromine chloride
and fluoride so because iodine is a detoxifier
you can have a little bit of a reaction where
it might be even worsening the skin or the
cystic acne or whatever but only for one week
and then those go away what I would do if
you had a reaction I would I would cut down
the dosage or actually I wouldn't take it all
wait for that to clear up and then take small
amounts gradually over time because if you
stop it it's like it's starting to work and
then you could have actually gotten some really
good results from it instead you stop taking it
and you're not going to get the benefit so just
realize that go slow with iodine or sea kelp if
you're going to take that but it does get rid
of heavy metals and it can create a reaction
iodine is really good for cystic acne though
too so a lot of people are trying to get rid
of that also it helps insulin resistance which
is very interesting we have a lot of videos on
that iodine is necessary in the improvement of
insulin resistance because it makes glucose more
sensitive to the body also it it helps cold feet
now if you have cold feet that can be a thyroid
issue and you would want to take seek help to
fix that so I I put a link down below of a very
high quality sea kelp if you wanted to find
one but I wanted to give you some information
about iodine and it's not just about the thyroid
it's about the entire body so thanks for watching